[Musique]
depuis plusieurs semaines les rayons du
soleil amène la douceur printanière
abeilles bourgeon première fleur le
jardin se réveille et pour lui redonner
des couleurs après l'hiver c'est le
moment de planter selon ses envies
ça peut être encore des bruyères ça peut
être ça peut être des sedum ça peut être
des hellébores des fois il faut il faut
se laisser convaincre par une fleur sans
problème et puis et puis là
collectionner dans son jardin du rose du
blanc ou du jaune comme un peintre qui
crée sa toile sans oublier l'importance
de protéger les nouvelles venues et
maintenant ce qui va être intéressant
c'est de venir
recouvrir notre terre par du copo qui va
permettre de d'éviter la levée des
mauvaises herbes parce qu'on est presque
lave de son jardin et puis de conserver
l'humidité au sol donc les végétaux en
une croissance encore plus importante et
plus rapide
un jardin prête à accueillir les amis et
les chasses aux oeufs à venir mais
surtout une dose de positif selon une
étude britannique
jardiner au moins 30 minutes par semaine
serait bon pour le moral